نحن لابد ان نمشي في اتجاهين اتجاه صلاح
التعليم من الصغر من كي جي 1 و كي جي 2
اصلاح تعليم كيف ينشا الطالب بالذات اذا
اراد انه يتخصص في الدراسات الشرعيه كيف
ينشا على مناهج عقليه فكريه كليه
المؤسسات في الدول الناميه لابد ان تنقح
في التراث وان تنقي وانا ضربت مثالين
بالحديث النبوي كذلك كتب التفسير فيها
كثير من الاقوال والاراء الغير منطقيه
يعني لما تقرا في الطبري بان سيدنا ادم
كان في الجنه وبعدين نام وبعدين ام لا
حواء قاعده جنبه انت مين انا خرجت من ضلعك
الايسر لما تقرا هذا في الطبري من يتقبل
هذا ربما الطبري معذور لانه جماع لكن نحن
في عصر المحقق تحقق كتب التفسير كتب الفقه
كتب الفقه مليئه بصور الان لا يمكن ان
تناسب وقتها تاريخيه لا يمكن ان تناسب
الذهاب